Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 31st, 2016 what's going on out? Yeah,
it's Halloween. Everybody happy Halloween. Oh, happy hollow. Fucking ween.
Happy all up. Fuck weed, Dah Dah, Dah.
You're a fucking teen. It's, you're too fucking old for candy. Um,
what's the cutoff?
What's the cutoff tonight when the kids come where you just want to be with some
of them just be like, dude, you're too fucking all cleo. Get outta here.
I'll feed you in a minute. Go on.
I'm telling you my cutoff is somewhere around like fucking 12
you know?
Even in around 10 they just start saying little wise ass cunty fucking things.
You know?
That's the hardest thing about being an adult around a kid is they think they're
so fucking smart and it's just like Douche. I was, I was your age.
I've been 10 I've been 12. Okay. Dad had been 2030,
40 almost up to 50. You're right. You dumb. Fuck. Do you think you think,
I don't know what you're doing. Do you think you're playing with my mind? Man?
I mean, just, we just want to say it too. Do you remember that? Your moment,
everybody's got to have that.
Do you ever have that fucking adult that just fucking, you know,
when your parents weren't looking,
just looked at you and just told you to shut the fuck up?
Yeah.
Probably doesn't happen nowadays because of all this smart phones and
everybody's going to video camera and the kid blogs about it.
Next thing you know, you get arrested for run or,
I dunno what I dunno about Cleo. Get out of here. Go on, go on. Um,
you know, but back then, I mean, that's the kind of Shit you could do.
I remember we were talking in church,
me and my brother and this dude fucking turned around and he goes, hey, he goes,
shut up.
He
just said that. He goes, we shut up. You know, it's just one of those things,
you know,
and my mother and I looked at my mother and she fucking put her eyebrows up
like, but yeah, we'll shut the fuck up. That doesn't happen nowadays. Apparel,
all my you, you don't talk to know much emotional abuse,
verbal abuse. No. Your kid needs to shut the fuck up.
So what, what our youth is,
does that show that fucking hour where they just stop being cute?
You know, they just stopped being cute and they get fucking annoying.
And then a kid, it goes over the hill where it just becomes like,
you know,
they're coming up to your thing and they got this shitty Grinch smirk on their
face. I'm telling you this fucking year does fucking year.
Some kid comes up with a smirk on his face. I go,
I'm not giving you any candy cause that look on your face.
This is what I want to say. But you can't because of that.
Look on your face and if you do anything to my mailbox or anything like that,
I'm going to fucking kill you. All right? You fucking pussy.
You don't even have a drive yet. The fuck out of here. Right. But you can't say,
you know, he can't, not, not today's America, not today's America.
Or you know what? Trump's going to bring that back.
Um, I've had such a bad experience, like all my life, all my laugh,
I have a little bit bizarre been, I've been waiting for like,
I couldn't wait to have a fucking house.
The kids came by to go trick or treating.
I mean I moved out and um,
well the first time I lived like in the upbeat attic of,
of a fucking old house that they turned into an apartment.
It was fucking hilarious.
And you had to like walk down the center of the apartment so your head head
wouldn't hit either side of the fucking roof. And uh,
I told you guys this right now, he didn't have a bed.
I slept in a sleeping bag and I would sleep right by the window because I
didn't, we didn't have any AC.
And then one night there was like some torrential downpour.
I was sitting the dream and I was on a boat or some,
some about water and I woke up just soaking wet. Um,
video is funny.
Ended up catching a cold and like the next day it was like July was like 89
degrees out of something. And I had a cold, like it was fucking November.
Um, Oh God, that fucking sucked. Um,
then I moved back in with my parents, got my shit together,
fucking finally graduated fucking college.
And then when I moved out I ended up going to New York City and people don't go
trick or treating in New York City.
They have places where they go where all the fucking candy is and they make sure
there's no fucking Weirdos there. Um,
and then when I finally moved out to La, I don't know,
people still didn't come to my first department is when I got my house,
you know, five years ago they was just like, all right,
now they're going to be coming. And I was fucking loaded for bear and I, you,
I did the bet on, I had the full size candy bars. Jesus Christ.
Cleal you're driving me nuts. Get over there and lay down. You kick.
There's no way to be mad at a dog for longer than four. Frustrated. Well,
three seconds. [inaudible] can you please lay down? Hey Buddy, lay down down.
Go on, lay down. There you go.
And the follow through. Thank you. Um,
I already can tell she's not going to sit there cause she's laying down,
but she has her ears up and she's just staring at me. You know what it is.
I had to get up early to do this fucking podcast cause I got a bunch of shit
that I need to do. So anyways,
people finally started coming to the fucking house. And uh, that's what I found.
You know, soon as the sun goes down the first, I know we always talk about this,
but you gotta admit it's true. The first like hour and a half.
It's the cutest fucking kids you've ever seen. The parents are great. Hey,
you know, it's just like a great, it's just, I dunno, it's fucking awesome.
The kids are adorable. And then somewhere around, I dunno,
two in seven and eight, it starts switching over and this just nothing but cons.
Like after like a quarter to nine, I mean,
just everybody see it's going to be a bunch of fucking,
oh man, you know something. What? Rent in this fucking house.
It's got this crazy driveway. I don't think anybody's going to come up here,
but next year I promise you guys I have to fucking,
I want to open a door and be like, ah Nah, you guys, you're too old.
You're too old. Look, he can go buy some candy. Get the fuck out of here.
But then you gotta worry they're gonna fuck up your house.
Even if they don't do it that night, they gonna do it another night.
Just be like, come on man, you guys are too old.
Maybe I'll just lie and be like, ah, sorry. I might've catty y'all taller.
You five what? Yeah, I'm out of candy. What do you got?
Yeah, there's the four. You're not four 11 fuck outta here.
You're five foot one. Bait it. Um
Oh y'all are. You know what you do is,
is what's the worst kind of fucking candy?
What's just a shitty old lady kind of candy. That's what you do,
you know with the, the fucking fruit in the middle of it. Like it real fruit.
Oh my God. I Dunno about you guy.
I don't know what grandmothers are like nowadays, but when I was a kid, man,
my grandma, my grandparents had the worst fucking candy,
at least one of them did. And then like the fuck,
I had a paper route and then there was like a bunch of old bitties and shit that
you know, coupled that never got married and shit or that damn fucking,
they're dead.
They fucking husband died and they'd always have like this little candy.
I have a piece of candy. Right. And I got a bite into, Ugh, God,
I didn't know what the fuck it was. It was just, it was just horrible.
Just, it just, you know, it was like,
did they put your perfume in the middle of this shit? I'm sorry. It was, it was,
I'm just saying it was disgusting. All right. So anyways, um,
I'm actually going to a Halloween party tonight.
I was going to make some pumpkin bread for the house, right? And I was like, uh,
at the party and neo's go on like I was, I got mad, I got so much shit to do.
And I go and I gotta make that Pumpkin bread. And then she just goes like, well,
why don't you just like not do that? We'll just, you know,
we'll go get a bottle of champagne.
And she always does that. She always goes,
you make your life so fucking hard. It's like, it's Pumpkin bread.
It's not that. It's just like, it's fucking, it's going to take me like,
you know, 10 minutes to put it together and then throw it in the fucking oven,
front hour. It's just a pain in the ass to do it. Why don't we just do this?
Like who the fuck? What the fuck?
You just be another asshole showing up with a bottle of wine as opposed to
showing up with Pumpkin bread.
Okay.
The fuck is, you know, I dunno. I don't know. Sometimes. Sometimes,
I don't know. Sometimes we don't fucking, we just don't see it.
Like I want to make my own steam dumplings. She goes,
I just buy them at trader Joe's. You know,
those are the, those are the times, you know what I mean?
Those are the times we just want to kind of smile and nod and just slowly back
towards the front door, get in the car, and just never come back again. Yeah.
In other words,
you'd lie to yourself that that's what you're going to do for the next 20
minutes. As you drive around, you know, talking to yourself,
it fucking red lights and you look over, there's some beautiful woman,
half your aides go and look at that crazy bald old guy and you just sit there
and you gotta be like, wow, I'm the crazy bald old guy.
No one's going to walk me out here.
And then you'd get you go back home and then that's it. That's how it works.
But every once in awhile, not actually once in a while,
more people than not can commit to that.
They can back their way out the front door and they can go through with it.
They take it all the way to the divorce, you know,
they go out, they get themselves a toupee, you know,
they painted orange, they get a red tie, they run for office,
they start people up at truck stops. Um,
this election is so fucked up that, uh, man,
that's got really quieted down. I have for the last fucking debate,
if that's what the fuck you want to call it. Um,
okay.
My big thing this year is I want to know, um,
It's just fucking loose, loose. It's fucking lose loose at the, at the thing.
And you know, something, as much as I've been sitting here fucking saying,
you know, Trump's a fucking racist and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's just like, well, you know, the Clintons are from Arkansas, so, you know,
I think that too fucking enlightened down there either, you know. Okay. Well,
you know, I know I'm just fucking being stereotypical here, but give me a break.
Oh, Bill and fucking I, Hillary, they grew up in Arkansas in like the fifth.
Okay. You might want to go back and look at some of those fucking racist,
you know, the racist people screaming at black people,
kids going to school for the first time.
You might want to try to pick her head out or something like that.
Give me a fucking break. You're from Arkansas.
I love that shit where just because you're a Democrat,
that just means that you know that you're not homophobic,
you're not racist or he, I have a buy wear blue,
I just don't fucking, or that if you're a republican,
then that automatically means that you, you know,
you want to bury babies in the backyard, you know,
unless they're fucking blue eyed white babies, you know what I mean?
Like that whole fucking dinner in the corporations and all that,
they're all fucking cuts, you know,
I know that cause I'm a [inaudible] and I'm somewhere in the middle.
I like to think I definitely lean more fucking left. But,
uh, I'm also contrarion and now I live out here in Hollywood and I just can't
fucking deal with these people out here. And, uh, that it's, it's driving me.
I don't think it's driving me to the right, it's,
it's driving me to say things on the right just to fuck with these people.
Like I love trash and Hilary out here.
It's one of my favorite fucking things to do.
Okay.
You know, I,
last night I was fucking around the stage and I was talking about that.
Let's talk about how, you know, well,
Hillary's some fucking Arkansas everybody and they all kind of laughed. I go,
you know, those those fucking fly overstates that you guys all shit on out here,
you know, and uh, you know, of course it gets fucking, I don't know,
whatever,
you know what the big thing is on this ballot is wherever the fuck you live,
more important than what,
or that orange headed fucking racist comment or that devil woman with her
fucking issues, right?
She lived in Arkansas in the 1950s. Jesus Christ,
write me a fucking break. Um,
[inaudible] you know what the biggest fucking thing is? Sorry,
I'm losing my train of thought here is those is all the props,
the state propositions, you know, and this is what pisses me off.
So I go to this website to try to figure out California 17 ballot measure
propositions explained.
All right? And uh,
all they do, they sort of explain the thing, but what they don't have,
what I cannot find is all the bullshit that is attached to each one of these
propositions.
Like this shit is so fucked up and I do not understand why this is never
addressed. Why on all these propositions, like no means yes, yes means no.
And then there's a little bit of maybe in there and then if you vote for the
fucking Shit, there's some other measure saying that, you know, yeah,
it's okay to a fucking stick, a baby in a snowbank for fucking, you know,
13 hours until it freezes to death or whatever,
however fucking long would would take, you know, I just can't,
I can't find anything that says all the shit that's attached to it.
Why can't the fucking ballot just be fucking the proposition?
Just be written clearly. So regular people understand it. Yes. Means yes.
No means no. And there's nothing else attached to it.
You know, like they'll say, all right, ah, there we go.
Proposition 51 allows the sales of 9 billion in bonds,
um,
to pay for, for new k, uh,
kindergarten to 12th grade and community college facilities.
The basics,
roughly 6 million students attend k two you don't have the fucking is
proposition 51 wants to address the needs by allowing the sale of 9 billion in
general obligation bonds to pay for buildings in modernizing K-12 and community
college. It's the first school bond measure on the state ballot since 2006.
It's unusual because it's sponsored by the building industry.
Okay. Right there.
The fact that it's sponsored by the building industry means they're going to
charge us up the fucking ass. And in the end, even though they get 9 billion,
they're going to come in with the fucking tab of about 15 billion and then
they'll be like, well,
we already started good Spiegel physically moved from [inaudible] to Bluto.
Typically the legislator would be the path for getting this kind of proposition
on the ballot, but it hasn't been able to do so in recent years. Yeah.
The fact that the building industry wants to do it.
You already know this is crooked, is shit.
What you're voting on about 7 billion in nearly ADC. Like this shit.
7 billion would be allocated to the K to 12 thing, and then what?
Another 2 billion would feed it for the community college.
I got to read all of this shit.
Supporters include developers, builders, school board officials,
and business groups. I don't want to get any of those people.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
Supporters say, all right. Uh,
supporters say many of our schools need repairs and upgrades to make them save
for our children. That's very vague.
Proposition 51 we'll will improve education overall and help expand space to
community colleges. Some more students can attend.
Opponents say prop 54 would add to the state debt,
which is already more than 400 billion.
How the fuck is California for an a billion in debt?
Bond measures should be passed locally.
Giving communities control of how the money is spent.
Yeah. Jesus. I mean, do you feel any closer?
All right, so there's one comment. Close the border.
Eliminate anchor baby citizenship and re-institute and re-institute of all
provisions of prop proposition one 87 then let's talk about building more
schools. Sorry, I used to always vote yes on these.
Now Sacramento has changed my vote.
I always vote no on school bonds.
Quid pro quo baby. What is a quid pro quo? Me?
Where the fuck is it?
Quid pro quo meaning I love that everybody else is dumb as me.
A favor or advantage granted or expected in return for something.
Oh, that doesn't get me any close to understanding it. Quid pro quo.
Jesus fucking Christ. What it, what am I on law and order here.
Quid pro quo means and explain an exchange of goods,
goods and services where one transfer is contingent upon the other English
speakers often is this tit for tat? Yeah, Jesus fucking Christ.
English speakers often use the term to mean a favor for a favor.
Phrases with similar means would include give and take tit for tat and you
scratch my back. I'll scratch yours. Quid pro quo.
I guess that's the fucking snooty way of saying that shit.
Let's go back to close the borders here so I can try to figure out what his
fucking point is. Oh, I get it. Close the fucking borders and then I'll fucking,
then I'll give money to this side. I see what the guy is saying.
I don't know if it's right or not. All right. Fuck politics. All right.
You know what I try. I fucking tried
all freckles has not flipped out about technology and I figured out how to watch
the NHL on my phone because so many in the room knew how to do it and they
walked me through it and at one point I started to get upset cause I go,
it's not going on. He goes,
what do you mean it's not going and it's supposed to go on down.
And I go and then I started getting mad. God, why would it go? Why? Why, why?
Why would it go on? It's me if I fucking it.
Just brought it down and bring it down. Bring it down. You know what I mean?
Like you ever see somebody like revving up the engine ready to do a burnout?
Then I brought it all the way down, you know, before the tire stop moving.
And I realized that was not the tires I was actually burning out the clutch.
It's one of the most disgusting things you'll ever see is somebody trying to do
a fucking burnout. And I don't know what happens.
I still don't quite understand. I've never done one.
I just never wanted to beat the shit out of my car.
I basically get it with the stick shift.
I don't know how you do it with an automatic, I've watched fucking the videos,
but it's basically you get your art premiums up, you let the clutch out,
and then you stomp on the fucking brake so your tires are already fucking going.
But somehow if you fucked that up,
you let the clutch out and you're revenue engine and Yang. Jan, Jan,
Jan, your tires aren't fucking moving and you burn out your clutch and it's,
it's the, I don't know what that smells like, but the smoke is evil. Look at,
um, all right, let's move on here. Oh,
did anybody watch the Patriots game yesterday? Clear.
Get over there and lay down every always in about you. Go on, go lay down,
go lay down. Um,
I can't even fucking begin to tell you how much I enjoyed that.
The fact that the fucking patriots beat the bills yesterday.
I didn't say this because I take a puff beforehand because I take a nod.
I get what bill Bellacheck does in his press conferences where he's like,
I'm not going to say anything negative about anybody.
I'm not going to give you any advantages because you fucking fat.
Cons in the media are going to take this and give bulletin board material for
the other team. I got to tell you,
watching the fucking buffalo bills and we played them when we had a third string
quarterback with a broken fucking hand or whatever the fuck was wrong with them.
How they got in his face before the game was such a Bush League fucking move to
the point like I've always liked buffalo. I might be done with that franchise.
Like I used to give a shit. I, you know, they lost four in a row.
Now I'm just like, you know what? Fuck them. You know,
it's like you're that insecure that you're not going to win the fucking game,
that you got to try to pull some shit like that. And I was just like that.
Then I was just thinking, you're like, you know what? Two great things happen.
We lost.
So now we don't have to deal with the pressure of the fucking undefeated season.
All of the extra media hype that comes if New England's going on defeated,
if you fucking Indianapolis with old fucking a, what a fuck's his name there?
Peyton Manning, you can be all the way to 13 and oh, nobody saying nothing man.
They're right down the street. Them cows. Right. So he took that away.
And then also I'm like,
the Patriots are gonna beat the shit out of this fucking team the next time
because of that bullshit.
Because I know in house they must've talked about it and there you go.
He gets 41 fucking points. Whatever the fuck we scored, I'm against you.
Having said all that,
I'd like to say a lot of positive things like tie Rod Taylors I can possible to
fucking tackle.
I know the bill's had a bunch of fucking injuries and I'd make those excuses,
but they don't give a fuck those fucking animals.
They don't give a shit.
They were talking all kinds of trash to a third string quarterback like they
would coming out on the field getting ready to lose another fucking Superbowl.
I love that. You fucking ringless. I love that you four and three. Hey Buffalo,
we're on our way to the playoffs. See you next year.
Fuckos Woo. Oh, I enjoyed that. I really fucking enjoyed that.
You know fucking Rex Ryan told them to do it too. Oh God.
I've been waiting to go off on this.
You fucking get out there and you fucking fucking fucking fucking cause we the
best fucking fucking in the fucking AC fucking east. Yeah,
go have another fucking hero. Your tub of Shit.
If you want to talk about cheating,
you know we let a little air out of the ball. He got fucking that,
that stomach gastric surgery. He's not phase of fat. Fuck. He cheated.
Letting air out of the ball.
He had a fucking choke out three quarters of his stomach.
So you could actually see his dick every once in a while. Ah, sorry.
Sorry. Anyways,
um, yeah, I and,
and I gotta tell you something else to fucking watching this world series.
I have gone back and forth,
back and forth and back and forth about who the fuck I'm rooting for. I mean,
how do you do it?
One team's waiting fucking 70 not quite 70 years, right?
68 years. Is that what it is yet? 68 years.
The other team has even been the fucker world series is 71 years.
And I know you guys think about bill, you're a fucking red sox fan.
How can we not for the cubs?
I was totally for the cubs until I saw the 30 for 30 on, on fucking Bartman.
And when I watched it, all of their a hey, let's play to,
you know, hey, you know, where the lovable fucking losers, we always show up.
We just root for him.
All of that went out the window the way that they fucking what the,
what they did to that kid. I just looked at that shit going like,
that's exactly what would have happened if seven in Boston did that. New York,
Philly, Cleveland, these cubs fans for all their fucking, you know,
Mr. Smith goes to watch Washington fucking a apple pie and Chevrolet way that
they did. They just like us. They're fucking animals.
I'm not saying they're as bad as bills. Fans are, that fucking franchise.
Those cons. At the time I was wearing a patriots hat. It was the bill's jets.
I was rooting for the bills.
I'm taking a piss in the bathroom and pushed me from behind while I was taking
the piss. What kind of a fucking coward?
Maybe there's a reason in the last four in a fucking row, you know,
I used to think it was because of madly Levy.
He was just too nice to win a fucking Superbowl and he went up against Jimmy
Johnson. Let's get him some hookers and a corvette, right? Um,
and fucking whatever that other guy's name is Jerry Jones with his real
housewife fucking looking face. Good Lord.
That guy always looks like, you know,
he got like first degree burns on his face or maybe like slightly like into the
second degrees, but he was like, all right,
he refused medical treatment and he just put some savvy on his face. Um,
I know I'm going hard this week. I don't know why. I have no idea why.
I'll tell you why. You know why?
Because last night I wanted to fucking come home and do my Goddamn podcast,
but my wife, you know, wanting to watch a scary movie. So I said,
okay, let's watch it. So we started watching that, but doka took,
took whatever the fucking that thing is. And I got about like,
I got about 40 minutes into that movie. It's like, honey,
I don't want to watch the rest of this. All right.
I hate watching scary movies because I, I buy in,
I fucking buy in and I just like,
I don't want to watch this thing terrorizing this woman in the kid for the next
fucking 90 guide.
They are minutes cause I know neither one of them is going to die.
And I'll eventually, they're going to figure out how to put,
put DACA took back into the fucking thing and then they're going to do something
with the book that lets me know that there's going to be another one.
Cause they're always, you know,
fucking horror movies can never just fucking end. You know what I mean?
Every one of them, they got to get greedy like Friday the 13th part fucking 97.
You know what I mean? Nightmare on elm street. You know,
they did like 20 of those hell raiser,
15 evil dead parts six. They just want to keep fucking going.
And uh, I dunno, I just, I just don't like fucking sitting there being,
having anxiety, you know.
And with each scene they gradually gonna ramp it up the first time.
Oh it's just a little bit of knocking and then there's a shadow and then,
you know, I was just like, the sinks going to, I got a bad feeling.
This thing's going to kill the dog and I don't want to fucking see that.
All right. They already foreshadowed in the book that that's what's,
what's going to happen. You know,
they kind of showed you basically with the pop up book, fuck off.
If you think I'm ruining this, it's, this is like paint by numbers.
Every fucking one of them. I get an upset because I just hate, so I was like,
I don't want to watch the rest of this.
So she ends up shutting it off and then she's like fucking pissed.
She's like fucking pissed at me. And it's just like, I like Westworld.
My wife doesn't give a fuck about Westworld.
I'm still on episode two because every night I want to fucking watch it.
She's like, Eh, I wanna watch the real housewives of fucking
St Louis or whatever the fuck it is. So anyways,
let me get back to the cubs thing. So right out of the gate,
not only is the country, it seems for the, for the Chicago cubs,
it's kind of having this vibe of this foregone conclusion that they're Kinda
gonna win this thing.
So I have family or I had family back in the day out in Ohio.
My grandmother worked for the Cleveland Press, you know, and, um,
way back in the day I had family, you know, I just had family about their right.
And so growing up I kinda was, you know,
I was always a red sox fan, but, uh, you know,
I Kinda, you know, through my relatives also kind of rooted for the Indians.
You know what I mean? Like, I didn't, I didn't mind the Indians,
even though they were in our division way back in the day, um,
that the tigers, you know what I mean, just cause of relatives,
cousins and all that shit. So I was just like, you know,
I kinda liked the fucking Indians and you know, that Steve Bartman Shit,
like the level that they took that to,
that's exactly what would have happened in Philly and all this shit.
And if it happened out in la, that poor kid would've got killed.
You know what I mean?
Or San Diego or Sacramento or Fresno or one of these fucking lunatic fucking
cities out here where they take sports Oakland way too seriously.
San Francisco, you know. Um,
so made me just kind of fucking sort of pull back.
And then also it's like I, you know what,
I'm kind of over these fucking cities that have two professional teams in one
sport. It's like Chicago won a world series.
They won it in 2005 and that whole fucking thing where it's like,
well that was just, there was for the south side of the city.
So what you need another one for the north side?
Fuck the white sox and the cubs. This shit, if she, one of them wins,
just fucking jump on a subway or walk three blocks downtown or uptown and join
the fucking parade already. Same thing with the Yankees and the mets,
the Lakers and the clippers and everything in fucking New York giants, jets,
Yankees meds, fucking rangers, islanders, Knicks and nets.
Just fuck off with that shit already. It's a New York team.
If they win by your championship hat and go down there and just be happy that sh
especially in New York, that you're so fucking filthy, stinking,
fucking rich that you can have eight teams where everybody else is doing,
doing backflips that they just have one in every sport. You know?
I know.
Isn't it amazing that New York has all those fucking teams and they don't win
that much? You think that Jesus Christ, you got eight,
eight at bats every fucking year. The fucking Yankees,
I swear to God, are like the sugar daddy of New York City. You know what I mean?
The giants are the favorite son and everybody else is getting read written out
of the will. That's basically how it works with the sports in New York.
Do you know what New York should get three teams in every fucking city?
Maybe they could fucking do something other than the Yankees and the giants.
I have totally fucking respect for them, but Jesus Christ,
the fucking necks should combine with the nets. You know,
make like a fucking dream team of those two shit shows.
Same thing with the ranges in the islanders. You know,
I don't know the jets and the mets, I don't know what they should do.
They should both retire and they should start playing bad man. Um,
oh Jesus Bell. Um, so anyways,
so I'm really fucking sitting there and I'm and love and seen Terry Francona
killing it and it gets all the way up to three games to one.
All right.
And I don't know, something happened. Okay. My Cleveland friends,
Comedians, one of them in particular just starts,
he's just talking all this shit and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And he starts to got, we were in the basketball,
now we're going to win the baseball, the, you know, you watch,
we're going on a fucking run. You Yadda with no fucking respect.
And he's talking to a fan from Boston, you know what I mean? It's just like,
are you going to win two in one fucking year? Yeah, we did that.
We did that a couple of times and then we went every fucking do.
We did all of this other shit. I'm not fucking throwing that in your face.
I'm always the guy going like add an aloe, say Dah. The team's tough.
I never believe we're going to do it until we do it. And then we do that.
I'm fucking psych and you can go back to my podcast.
I wasn't even a conduit beat Seattle.
So these guys are acting like such fucking cons. You know what I mean?
Oh, we got Lebron. We're going to fucking do it again this year. Oh, the Brown.
Oh you mean the guy that you guys are burned his Jersey and you're all done with
first. He called that one all Paul verse,
he called that one Paul Versey fucking when he was in Miami and these Cleveland
fans were saying, fuck that guy, blah blah, blah, blah. First he said to him,
you guys are all going to be sucking his dick when he comes back to town.
And they were like, no way. That's never going to happen while it's happening.
That whole city's on their fucking knees.
So anyways,
so at some point after they went up three games to one, I went back to the cubs.
The reality is,
is I don't give a shit who wins this fucking thing because it's going to be
great for one city. It's going to be devastating for the other city.
Um, obviously, but so here's the deal.
This is what's at stake with this world series. If the cubs win,
the Indians become the cubs.
They become the ones that have gone the fucking longest. All right?
So they can't fucking lose. All right? If Cleveland wins,
all right? Not only the cubs, still the cubs,
as far as my quick research research showed me the next people in line for
second place would be the cult 45 slash Houston Astros that started in 1962 in
1962,
the Chicago cubs were already 54 years into their drought.
Okay.
1962 is 54 years for where the fuck we are right now.
Right?
So the Astros are 54 years into their drought where the cubs were in 1962 and
the cubs are now twice that at one oh eight.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
Does that mean that you should go play the lottery right now?
54 62 one zero eight.
I have no idea what that fucking means. It's just, you know, one of those,
one of those number things. Um,
okay.
But I gotta tell you, uh,
it's almost fitting that if the cubs are gonna win it,
that they would torture their fucking fans to this level and it's fitting that
if the Indians were going to lose it,
they would go up three to one to lift their fucking team's hopes.
This is why I think the cubs are gonna win.
If Terry Francona wasn't in that Dugout, the master, by the way, he, he needs,
that guy needs a, a nickname like the assassin.
He needs like a boxer nickname. Like remember lights out James Tony,
you know,
or the execution or Bernard Hopkins that he needs a name like that.
It's just said he doesn't look like that. But that's exactly what that guy is.
All right. What I'm saying is
because of what these teams had done to their fans,
it would be fitting that the fucking cubs wouldn't just go in and win the
fucking thing. So their fans could just relax and finally enjoy your series.
They would have to go down three to one before they'd come back.
And then Cleveland couldn't just lose the series.
They'd have to go up three games to one.
So this is what's crazy about three gear up, three games to one. You're like,
holy fuck,
you're starting to take the wire off the champagne bottle at that point, right?
But then all of a sudden you fucking lose game five and just instantly,
it's like, holy fuck, if we lose the next one, it's all tied up.
So now the pressure is on the Indians. I'll tell you,
the cubs are going in there. They're playing loose.
They got nothing to lose other than fucking 108 year drought.
I don't know who's on the mound. I don't know what. But, um,
I'm going to say the obvious. The cubs gotta go.
They gotta they gotta score early and make the fucking Indians tighten up.
That's what the fuck they got to do. Or uh,
that's what's going to happen at game six.
Either the cubs are gonna score early. Indians fucking tighten up. Yeah.
And then lose the game and then we get a game seven.
Or if the Indians go up early, it's going to be a bloody Beth.
It's gotta be a shit show. Um,
I'm hoping the first thing happens because I want to see,
I want to see a game seven against a team that hasn't won an 108 years and a
team that hasn't won it and fucking, uh, what does it, 68 fucking years? 68.
It's adorable to a red sox fan. That's fucking hilarious. I mean, I give a fuck.
That's like this. Whether we were there in like the 70s, right?
What was 68 for us? I was at the mets, let's see.
1918 to 1978. That's 60 years,
right? And I 86.
I was 1986. So you just did bill Buckner. Go fuck yourselves.
You know,
you just did tell bacter as far as where I'm coming from,
you got to go another fucking a another 18 years to 2004,
so I guess I won't root for the Indians. I can, I fucking, I don't know.
My relatives got me into the Indians. I don't know what to do.
I don't know who to root for here. You know,
I'm root farm gluten for a game seven for game seven and then they're going to
go up against each other and one team's finally gonna win that critical game
seven and get the monkey off their back.
And then another one is just going to add another giant cinder block right on
the fucking heart to their fans. It's kind of, Oh God,
this one has trained right re written all over it. All right,
let me read a little bit of fucking average advertising, art, cheeses,
the appeal. You didn't fucking copy and paste them. Um,
I hope by the way you guys are watching the series because it's,
it's been unbelievable. What a fucking great series it's been. Um,
oh Christ, what am I doing? Come on bill. Click here. Click there. All right.
How many do we got here? All right. Okay, here we go. Oh, Luke crate everybody,
give me the loop. Are you looking for [inaudible] collectibles,
housewares and more and more from your favorite pop culture franchise?
We've got you covered. This is how like hipsters and I,
I guess nerds get laid, you know,
this is all about Luke crates should be like nerd crate, you know,
and just be like a pocket pussy in there or something. Uh,
we've got you covered.
Lou Crate offers a range of Geek and Gamer items for less than $20 a month.
Gamers are weird. They're either total nerds or they're like fucking jocks.
Have you noticed that
like video games kind of transcend like the whole, uh,
what was that Matthew Broderick movie war games sort of thing? You know,
we get the underwear on top of your head and you're like trying to make a woman
through your computer rather than just fucking get no hooker.
Like a normal kid who plays sports with hand eye coordination. You just,
you know,
cause what it is is nerds don't know how to flag down a hooker like were an
athlete, you know, sends the signal to, to his athletic hand, you know,
and just brings them in. All right.
You want to bring your Luke to the next level,
get a bigger box with even bigger lube with loot crate DX.
If you're more than the to,
I would love to see the sizes of these fucking t-shirts. What do they start at?
Um,
I just picture everybody who goes to comic con looks like a young bird for lunch
. Bruce for Lance, she was at fucking guy with the red glasses.
Who thinks he's fucking hilarious and writes all the speeches for people.
Um, he's really the craft of writing jokes and he has those Sally, Jesse,
Raphael Glasses. Um, if you're more than,
than the type to where you're Geeky, he looks like, uh,
like you know where the wild things are, like the way he has his hair and shit.
Um,
if you're more than the type two where your geeky heart on your sleeve than Lou,
where, sorry.
Our monthly wearables and accessories subscription is the droid you're looking
for. Um,
that shell running up your spine isn't your imagination. It's loot crates.
October theme horror.
We're taking over 40 years of creepy campy bloody icons and putting them in this
month's loot crate. Channel.
Your best final girl with items from the walking dead nightmare on elm street.
Friday the 13th Texas chainsaw massacre and Halloween.
What's final girl? I'm going to look that up.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe. Well,
it's the fucking 31st. The 19th of what?
I'm that months crate. And when the cutoff happens, then it's over.
Make sure to head over to
www.lucrilucrate.com/burr enter the code burger to save $3 off any new
subscription today. Just go to the website.
I Dunno what the fuck they're offering now.
I'm sure there's some soda horror movie that had a Turkey in it, right?
So that'll take you into November. Oh yeah. What's his face?
Um, what's his face though? Did Reservoir dogs, Quentin Tarantino?
He did. That movie affects your giving or that, all right. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody, um, guys, you know,
to go to dollar shave club for a fantastic shave there. Uh,
what you probably don't know is that they have other amazing products too. Uh,
the quality is the best on the market.
Their body washes gray and won't dry out.
Your skin are pre-shave and post shave stuff keeps your skin soft and smooth.
Um, there's stuff will key.
I have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks. Oh,
well it must've just came from the mint man, cause money's pretty filthy, right?
You don't want to put that anywhere near you. A dollar shave clubs,
a got stuff for your hair, for your face, for your underparts,
for everywhere you want to keep you and to keep you feeling and looking fresh.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see they the best grooming products out there and they're affordable
right now.
Your is right now is your chance to see for yourself why so many people love
dollar shave club. If you're not a member yet and have never joined,
now's the time. You'll get your first month of raises for free.
Just pay shipping and that's only a few bucks. Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burger that's dollar shave club.com/burn and it's
actually a great shit. You know what I mean?
You look and smell great when you go on a date. You know what I mean?
That's good for the ladies. You know,
maybe there'll be a little less upset and you're going to make your move that
night. Um, alright. What do I want to talk about now?
Let's go. Let's go to uh, oh, I went down to 'em.
I went down to lago last night.
Been slugging through my new fucking bullshit.
Trying to see where the, uh, the new hours gonna come from.
And uh, I dunno. We'll see. We'll see.
All I know is I don't have any fucking road gigs til February,
so I can just totally chill out.
I've been working out and eating like a fucking animal though. Yeah,
I made this pumpkin bread and shit. You know,
Rogan gave me some of that elk burger.
I made it late last night and then had a slice of Pumpkin bread after it.
So it's weird. It's like I'm in really good shape, but I also got this belly.
Um, but, um,
yeah,
I dunno. Like I love the fucking holidays.
And to me the holidays is you throw down your cookie,
you make stuff for your friends. You know what I mean? Fuck that.
I'm not getting a fucking bottle of champagne. You know what?
I'm going to finish this fucking podcast and I'm going to go out and make some
Goddamn pumpkin bread and right. And I'll show my wife.
I'll show her who's boss, by the way. You guys really enjoyed that too.
Our podcast. Huh? Um, I think we just went into a zone.
The 12 podcasts is a long ass fucking time,
unless you're hanging with Joe Rogan, uh,
who I hung out with in a finally got him on the podcast last Thursday.
If you missed it. Um, once again,
he has a new amazing standup special called triggered. Um,
we talked about everything from hunting elk and wild fucking bore to,
uh, working out UFC shit, election stuff, stand up comedy.
Um, just had a great fucking time. Um, but his specials on Netflix,
so definitely check it out if you get a chance. And uh, all right,
let's get back to 'em. Let's get back to the, uh,
the podcast here. Oh, F one action and F one action.
I totally missed the fucking race, but I read up on it.
Lewis Hamilton wins again. For those of you sort of keeping score,
now that I've been keeping score, um, you get 25 points.
If you win 18 for second, 15 for third, that is 12, 10, eight,
six, four, two, one. Right? That's the top pile. The top fucking 10 works. Um,
Cleo, you could not be more adorable right now.
What it is is she wants f o d I got up a little bit to do this podcast,
so now she's come over. She sat down next to me,
her ears are down and she's rested her head on my arm and she's just staring at
me like, I don't know what's going on.
Okay.
All right dude. I've got another 20 minutes. Just fucking relax. No, no, no,
no. Not coming up on the couch. Go on. Go lay down. Go lay down. Go lay down,
cleo. Get out of here please.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. What the fuck again? It get out of here. Clio.
Get off of the couch. Way down. Oh, now she's needy.
All right. Anyways,
so Rosberg had a fucking league in the last two fucking races.
Hamilton is one boat,
so he's shaved 14 fucking points off of the lead.
All the fucking Nico had to do is fucking win one more race.
I felt if he could have won it yesterday, he could have wrapped this thing up.
I'm kind of glad that he didn't cause I want to see the person fucking wrap it
up. Um, so the next race I believe is in Brazil,
which is not until November 13th. And I apologize to, uh,
F1 fans because I know I got into this shit and then I've just dropped the ball
and like the last four or five ones, but I,
I'm fucking living in this goddamn house. I fucked up. I forgot that,
that it was this week and that I actually figured out through apple TV is some
shit that I patiently worked my way through and actually figured out,
um, that I could actually get a, was it NBC sports?
Is that the name of the channel?
And I could have watched the game of shit to watch the race.
So I got to go home today.
My house around the fucking corner taped that fucking thing.
By the way, the kitchen is just come to a grinding fucking halt.
I don't know why,
but they're still telling us that they gonna Finish on fucking time.
So whatever, whatever,
I'm sure they will fucking sure they will. All right, let's get out of this.
Let's, let's do some, uh, can I talk about now? Did you guys watch Clemson,
Florida? Fucking amazing game. I also watched the, uh, limbs,
Clemson, Florida, Florida state. Then I also watched, uh,
Florida fucking Georgia. And you know, I was thinking when I first saw it,
I was just like, man, I got to go to that game.
I got to go to that game in Jacksonville,
the biggest outdoor cocktail party in the world as they say. And I'm like,
I bet the fans are cool with each other. They're fucking, you know,
cause it's a neutral site, you know,
everybody's just psyched to be away from their house. Sorry,
I'm fucking you on here. Um, Georgia scores first,
they cut to the Georgia fans in the stands and I clearly see this guy turned
around not facing the field and just giving the finger to the Florida fans above
them. And I'm just like, wow. All right. It's at that level. Okay.
It's at dead fucking level. I D I, you know,
I really had no interest in going to that game. I'd want,
I want to go to this swamp.
And I've been to what Georgia home game between the hedges and been to a
Jacksonville verse, Bengals Games. So I felt like I'd been to that stadium,
but after seeing it I was like, fuck way.
And it looks like fun and I always have a great time at Jacksonville.
Everybody shits on Jacksonville. It's a good fucking time.
If you take the stick out of your ass, um, you can go to a gun range,
shoot guns with a, with a, with the fucking silence around. All right, clear.
The only thing I'm going to do is just sit here and pet you as I do the rest of
this. All right. All right, Westwood Dear Bill.
Uh, glad you love Westworld. For some reason he wrote westward in the beginning.
Glad you love Westworld. Uh,
I look forward to hearing your thoughts and the rest of the season season. Um,
if you like that and you're looking for a great movie to watch,
check out the 13th floor.
It came out in the late nineties and deals with similar themes.
Are you into reading fan theories? A common one now, uh,
that is a non spoiler is that Ed Harris,
his character and the Nice guy who's new to the park or the same person.
And other claims that it's actually all on Mars.
Oh, for Westworld. Yeah. Well I gotta get caught up before people ruined shit.
I'll definitely check out, uh, the 13th floor.
And I think I'm going to watch an episode, episode three of Westworld,
cause I think they're up to five at this point.
I'm going to watch that today and I'm going to get caught up in, uh, you know,
cause my wife fucking cheated on me with TV. You know what I mean?
When you guys have your shows, right?
We watched that show below deck with [inaudible] skin on there, right?
And uh, it's just,
it's a reality show that we can both watch because they're always in the fucking
Mediterranean. They got a fucking yacht. It's the Shit we always think, ah,
we should do that. It'd be fucking awesome.
And then you look up the prices and it's like the price of a house to rent one
of those fucking things.
You gotta be like Beyonce and Jay z.
Like both of you can sell out the rose bowl on any given fucking night.
You know, you gotta be to that level of wealth to fucking justify.
Do you realize the two of them are almost worth $1 billion?
So for then the blow 250 grand and a fucking yet is like,
let's just say you're worth $100 million if you're with $100 million,
250 grand is like 0.25% of your money, right?
Cause a million is like 1%. Right? So I don't know how to work that out.
It's like 25% of 1% whatever the fuck that is of your money.
And there were 10 times set so that that's like you and I, Hey,
you want a yacht for a week and you take a penny out of your pocket and you
break it into four fucking pieces and just hand it to them. Hey, you go,
there you go. Yeah, we'd like, uh, all the amenities. Um,
anyways, I will definitely be, uh, be checking that out.
Ed Harris is like, as always,
as always one of the greatest actors of all fucking time. Um,
I'll watch anything that, that guy's in. I swear to God,
the only thing I never saw is he was the one where, Oh God, Yo,
fuck,
I'm the only one I never saw was the one when he played the painter and that got
nominated or he got nominated for an Oscar. So I still haven't seen that one.
So I gotta check that out. All right.
Old Toys a dear Billy potato head.
I love that. That's a good one.
Cause that kind of shits on my Irish heritage and then also makes fun of the
shape of my head. Um, if, if, if you ever have kids,
will you try and expose them to toys that you enjoyed as a child?
You strike me as a matchbox car kid.
I don't force the toys of my childhood on my kids,
but I've put a couple army men in their general area to give them a chance to
play like I did. I am a huge, um,
agree or of that proponent of that opponent of that proponent. Oh,
that's what proponent means. You're pro, right? I never knew what that meant.
I just kind of figured that out. Oh, opponent proponent.
Oh, pumpkin bread pro pumpkin bread. I get it. Um,
yeah, absolutely. I absolutely, uh,
I absolutely will do that. Um,
my big thing is playing catch and uh, you know,
I'm going to buy a fucking, I'm going to buy a, a,
a lefty glove for myself is what I'm going to do,
cause I can throw a little bit with my left hand and rather than just sitting
there firing it into my kid, I'd fucking, uh, I'm just gonna,
I'm gonna go to the left hand. We were doing that yesterday.
We had a football right.
He's placed in at where rent here has his fucking great pool.
So it was halftime of the Florida game and we're out there smoking cigars and
shit. And we finished that up. We've got the game turned up loud.
So the game became, there was four guys, right?
So you had to on one side of the pool, two on the other side of the pool.
So you had to throw with your opposite hand,
first person that sent it into the pool or if he had a catchable ball and it
fell into the pool was a, I dunno, whatever the fuck it was,
was was that thing,
that word you can't fucking say anymore cause everybody gets offended and it's
not a racial slur, but it is, uh, you know, you know, you know the word. Um,
nobody said it, but we all know we are, you know, without saying, yeah,
we're all the guys. Like that's what it means. Um, so anyways, uh,
yeah I would definitely do that was, I was not a matchbox car kid.
I W I was Corgi cars.
We used to call them core g cause we didn't know it was pronounced Corgi until
we got older.
And I'm so old that I remember when they had rubber wheels on them and I had the
giant oil truck. I was big, I had all the race cars,
I had the Johnny players' special,
I had the Jackie Stewart Elf car and my mother doesn't throw shit.
So I still have all of them. Um, I had one of those, you know,
that kind of racing where the car just looks like a giant doorstop.
Um, it wasn't Formula One, it wasn't, it's not indycar racing.
It's not open wheel. You know what the car looks like,
a water slide that you could,
you could slide from the fin all the way down to the front.
I don't know what kind I had a white and red, one of those, um,
Lincoln logs, Lego, Lego blocks.
Um, you know, stuff like that.
I think it's big to not have to keep your kids, you know,
I dunno the,
you gotta get 'em outside and you gotta you got to keep them in their own. Like,
I don't know. I have such a hatred of computers and iPads and all of that shit.
Um, and kids just love them. I mean, they go up to it like, you know,
liquid television type of shit. You know, back in the day, the MTV,
I remember that graphic. I used to just make me want to sit down and watch it.
Um, I dunno, Mr Potato Head, I don't know about that.
Definitely like board games. I think it'd be fun playing cards.
I think it's cool to expose your kids to that, you know,
so they have like that old school shit. Like was it always the greatest cycle?
Like for me, if I met a some woman,
I took her out on a date and she had, she had some old school stuff about her,
you know what I mean? That, that stuff that was sort of passed down.
I think that's really like a cool thing.
And I think a like some shit like playing cards,
playing catch, like going outside, it's just like,
you know, riding bicycles, just like all that shit is going away.
And um, I'm not one of these old people that I look at young kids and be like,
you know, what are they doing today? They're fucking nuts. And these kids today,
they don't get it. And it's just like, um,
I totally get why they're doing it because I had to tap out grand theft auto
three in like 2003 or 2004 Id.
I unplug my playstation and stick it in the back of the closet.
I literally just one day, it was like the fifth day in a row,
I was just playing all day long and I could not stop.
I had already beat the game, I got the cheats, I did all of that shit.
And then I was just going on rampages every night to shoot up to city.
And um, I just,
you know, I kinda just lost everything else in my life.
I wasn't writing jokes and all that shit. So that was like 13 years ago.
So I can't imagine how amazing the Games are.
And um,
like the virtual reality goggles and all of that shit,
I can't even fucking imagine like how you get your kid to go in the backyard and
just have a game of catch. Like to me that's the greatest fucking thing ever.
I think it's a great way to communicate with your kid,
you know what I mean? Cause you, it's like you're doing,
that's another activity going on. So they're not really paying attention.
You can praise them when they're doing well, you know,
build up their confidence and then you just slide and how is it going at school?
You know, and then you just read them fast. It's going great. All right,
so it's going good. And VA, same kind of look down on, you know, it's all right.
Oh, it's a matter of what's going on and they can kind of open up to you.
I think it's like a great way to, uh,
I think it's really important early on to be able to do that.
To have your kid be able to come to you if they have a fucking problem is a,
a is a huge thing. But um,
how you sit there with a glove and a ball and a how that competes with putting
on fucking reality glasses and you feel like you're going to fucking base jump
off of a building or whatever the fuck they do.
I don't know what the fuck they do with those six. Um, yeah, that's a, uh,
that's, that's a difficult, that's a difficult one. I love Lincoln logs. I lie,
I didn't like Lego blocks. He stepped on them and your bare feet,
they fucking hurt at the Lincoln logs did. But like that plastic shit.
I wasn't into that as much as a, the Lincoln logs are cool.
We used to fucking build those things. We build houses and then we would,
you know what they're Corgi Corgi car, Corgi cars,
whatever the fuck are they called, drive them around.
We'd have traffic jams and all of that type of shit.
We had names for everybody that drove the cars.
I remember I had all the fucking race cars in, in all my,
uh, it's weird.
They drove like a formula one car to work and then they drove the trucks.
I had trucks and race and cars.
Then my other brother, who's a total fucking gearhead,
he actually liked like the real looking cars,
like a Volkswagen bug, like a station wagon.
Like he wanted to look like the cars that you could actually fucking drive. Um,
I know my mother didn't throw all of those out. Jesus Christ. It's fucking nuts.
They're all up in the attic somewhere. All right. Election Bill.
The election is right around the corner. A couple of weeks ago. You,
you'll eulogize the great barrier reef. Any last words for this election?
Uh,
not the country as a whole because I don't think it'll fall apart by an imagine.
This has exposed the side of our country that we've been able to keep under
wraps for awhile,
which is that no one ever pays attention to anything unless it's an easy talking
point. Yeah.
Um,
not everything is more fucked up than we know or would like to admit.
What's the worst thing that will happen if either candidate wins?
Uh,
well if Trump wins,
the worst thing is we're going to have to listen to all these European countries
talk about how dumb Americans are, especially people in England.
And I just want to say to them like, you know what,
what if you threw out the person every 48 years?
And I would love to see what the fuck you end up with. You know what I mean?
Some years it's just not a good draft. That fucking, uh,
whatever the fuck his name is. Tony Blair, that guy's been in this since Bush.
Not even saying that guy's good,
but you just get somebody in there and they just stay there until they die.
Does the have like Margaret Thatcher's job. Oh, the original Hillary Clinton.
Hillary Clinton can't even say her fucking name. Well,
what's the worst that will happen? Um,
I don't know if Trump wasn't such a fucking jerk off if he wasn't such a jerk
off. It's really what the country needs.
You need somebody who isn't a part of the fucking system. You don't,
but you just can't have a guy like that in there.
And then Hillary is just going to be more of the fucking same.
It's just going to keep driving this country towards ruined.
Do none of them talked about the population problem?
None of them talked about the nationwide heroin epidemic.
None of them talked about genetically altered food.
None of them talked about fucking global warming.
Maybe they touched on it for a second. They haven't said Shit.
They're not going to do anything.
None of them going to try to stop the banks put them in fucking line.
That building another real estate bubble. I'll tell you,
it's fucking hilarious out here is they are building up la like I've never
fucking seen.
They bought up the house of Blues right across the street from the fucking, um,
from the fucking uh, uh, comedy store.
They play like $28 million for the thing. They're going to put these,
these high rise fucking million multimillion dollar fucking condos in there.
It's like, who the Fuck gonna Afford to buy those things? All right.
And this is the thing, after 2008, after we saw what happened,
they fucking gave the house. None of the bankers went to jail.
They gave him the houses back so they could do it all over again.
They're building another fucking bubble.
And I'm already calling it right now by fucking 20, 21, 20, 22 or some shit,
there is going to be a bunch of empty fucking condo.
Fucking high rises going along the sunset strip and they have knocked down the
rainbow room, the Roxy, the wix whisky, house of Blues,
maybe the comedy store, they're gonna wipe out all of these fucking things.
There's going to be nobody in those buildings.
And even if they are in those buildings,
they gonna have no fucking place to go cause they knocked down all the cool
places to hang out on sunset strip. It's so fucking stupid. You know,
I was getting gassed the other day and another place on the sunset strip and
this guy said, I say, yeah, you're on the gas station. He goes,
I wish I did this property just sold for 14 million bucks. And you know,
they're knocking down the two buildings next to it and they're going to put up a
fucking, you know, a 170 unit fucking, I dunno,
I just don't know where all these people are going to becoming.
That can afford to pay. I just don't know where they're going to come from.
Um, if what I heard, you know,
at least the ones on La Cienega that was like oil money, you know,
like Saudi Arabian money came in and they, they don't give a fuck. I mean,
they get money forever. Um, I dunno.
Uh, what's the worst thing that will happen if either candidate comes in is that
they're not going to stop what's already going on.
And I gotta be honest with you, I don't even think like, you know,
all the Bernie Sanders and all those types of people,
you would literally need an army of those people and then they would need
bulletproof vests to fucking,
that's how powerful corporations are.
And that's how off the fucking rails we are.
Um,
I dunno,
which is why I'm trying to focus on the propositions and I wish if anybody can
find a fucking website out there that not only lets me know what I'm voting for
but lets me know what is attached to it.
Like cause who doesn't want to improve the schools, you know.
Um,
but you know, whenever they have stuff like that, like, hey,
let's clean up the drinking water,
then they attach all this other evil shit underneath it.
Um, I dunno.
I Dunno. It's, it's all very overwhelming.
So it's so fucking overwhelming that you're asking extend up comedian,
what's going to happen or maybe you just did cause you want to hear me make a
fucking ass of myself. Um, all right, here we go. Cool guy.
Terrible in bed.
Okay.
Oh Jesus. All right. Uh, dear Billy Bush bear.
Uh, I'm a 20 year old female college student. Um,
I go to holy cross.
Oh, in, oh you said is I go to holy cross. Okay.
I go to holy cross in Worcester. Um,
I had a boyfriend for the first three years of college and now I'm single.
I hooked up with a guy that I didn't know was kind of an asshole.
He sort of popular and seemed friendly. One drunk at night.
I did the worst thing I could do, fed his ego. Um,
had I known he was a moron in a pompous Douche bag, I would not have done this.
I'll save you the reasons why he's a Douchebag,
but just picture lame eighties preppy bully who thinks he's God's gift.
Again, I didn't know this because I had never paid attention to him.
Well after we hooked up,
he told some people that I told them he was the best fuck I ever had a this
found its way back to me and bill. I was shocked. Why?
Because he was the worst fuck I ever had. A,
he had no idea what he was doing. He was, for lack of better words,
not present. No rhythm and average at best.
I wasn't mad at this because it was my choice to hook up with him.
But now he's putting words in my mouth.
I really just want to tell someone how bad he was and wait for it to get back
around to him. What is my move here, Bill and or Nia? Well, wait a minute.
Did you say he was alright
one drunk at night? I did the worst thing I could do.
Feed his stupid ego. Does that mean that you slept with them?
I can't tell if you buy, feed his ego. You, you,
he was so bad. You felt like you had to say something nice.
Now there's no fucking way. You said there's no way. You said he was the best.
Fuck. Um, I think you're saying, yeah.
Yeah. I think you're saying that you, you fed his ego by hooking up with them.
Had I known he was a moron and a pompous dude. Okay,
so he's walking around saying that you said,
and you're also saying he's putting words in your mouth,
so I'm assuming that you never said that,
so fed his ego means that you fucking hooked up with them.
That's what I'm guessing. I don't fucking know. Christ they speaking radios.
Um, I wasn't mad at this because I'm,
well, oh, this is a tough one.
I would, I would call him up.
Then when he picked up, I'd be like, why are you walking around saying that?
I said you were the best fuck I ever had. I never said that. Okay.
I never said that. Okay.
And hear what he says and you know something. There might be a thing.
This is a thing, this fuck. A lot of these guys like this,
a tremendously insecure, maybe he knows.
He doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
So he's walking around saying that so he can feel better about himself because
he feels that awful about himself and he feels so fucking awful about himself
that not only does he got to go that big,
that the fucking way he feels about himself is such a big thing that it does,
that he doesn't even think that that's going to get back to you or he doesn't
even consider your fucking feelings.
So you can either be the biggest person and know that this person is,
I'm tremendously insecure and walks around and probably doesn't like themselves,
which is a fucking horrible feeling to have and just take peace with that.
Or
you can call the guy out, which I kind of like,
okay.
And, and I, you know, and at that point you gotta be, listen, uh,
if you were the best fuck I ever had,
I would have said that to you and just leave it at that cause you haven't sold
him that he's completely fucking inept. You know what I mean?
But you're also kind of putting the guy in check. Um,
and then you have your final option,
which is you can go around saying that he wasn't the best fuck I ever had.
He's fucking terrible in bed. And then, you know,
what happens is everybody just gets to sit back and enjoy watching you guys
fucking do this shit. I understand why you'd want to do it.
Um,
I dunno, I don't do the revenge thing.
I kind of go to the person that's doing whatever they're doing that's fucking
annoying me and I just kind of chop the head off there and, uh,
and then if somebody comes up to me and says what they said, I would say a,
I would just say to him personally, yeah, that isn't true. I never said that.
I Dunno. I Dunno what the fuck to do. I'm sorry that this happened to you.
I'm at 20 years of age.
It's probably hard to understand a lot of this shit that I'm saying that of what
that guy feels about himself. But, um, you know,
you can't have somebody walking around saying shit like that about you.
So I would, first thing I would do, I would confront the guy,
call him up and be like, why are you saying that? I never said that,
you know? And, uh, if you continue to say that,
and if he kind of goes around to the loo,
if he continue to say that you're leaving me in a position here,
that I have to tell them the truth. Okay.
You're not the best fuck I ever had. All right. I Dunno. It's just,
I don't know that that's, you know, guys,
if you listen to this thing and you're a young person,
that's such an fucking asshole thing to do. All right?
That's totally coming from your own goddamn insecurity. All right? And, uh,
as an older, wiser fucking man, you know,
I wish that somebody older told me that when you hook up with somebody,
you keep your fucking mouth shut. Um, you know what I mean?
You're quiet about it. You know, it happened. Who gives a fuck?
Who knows? You know what I mean? That's, it's an insecure fucking move.
And just sit there and then she did this and it did dead. She fucking did this,
like that's a really fucking asshole thing to do. And um,
and women,
if you hook up with the guy and he's fucking terrible or he's got a little Dick
and all that type of shit, right? Uh,
if he's not out there talking shit for you to walk around,
fucking doing that too. That's another fucking asshole move.
It's an asshole move either way. And in this case, the guy's the asshole. So,
um, I dunno, you know something, if you can hang on until Thursday,
I'll run it by near a, I'll ever run again and I'll run it by her.
It's just that she's still sleeping here. So, um, anyways.
All right, let me a, that's it for the questions.
Let me read the last two advertisements here and then, uh,
I got some pumpkin bread to make. Alright. Uh, SeatGeek uh,
buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long time.
It's always been hard to find the best deal for that game or show you want to go
to. And none of those older ticket sites want to change that,
but it Siki kids different.
They've come along and created an amazing app and website that makes it easier
than ever for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Siki does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal and Siki wants to help you get
the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on seek is given a grade based on value.
You will immediately see why any underpriced seats you mainly see any
underpriced seats and be able to find the best deals fit for your budget.
Best of all my listeners get a $20 off rebate.
They're first seeking purchase to get $20, uh,
to get your $20 rebate on tickets, download the Siki app,
go to the settings tab and click add a promo code.
Enter Promo Code Bar seek equals send you $20 in after you've made your first
ticket purchase. Uh Oh after you've made your first ticket purchase,
download the Siki gap and enter the Promo Code bird today. All right,
and stamps.com they're old friends here. Some small businesses still thinking,
think an expensive postage.
Meda is the only way to get postage without having to go to the post office,
but they are
wrong. Wrong, wrong.
The stamps.com ah,
with stamps.com you can easily print postage for any letter or package using
gesture,
computer and printer a no marks to hardware to buy no longterm contracts.
stamps.com can save you at least 50% compared to a meter plus.
You can do more with stamps.com then you can with the meter,
like send package tracking information to recipients with one click.
The choice is clear. stance.com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I've been using stamps.com for years from my show, uh,
for my posters.
Actually it makes mailing and shipping really convenient right now.
Sign up for stamps.com use my last name burpee.
You are to get a four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and
a digital scale scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in bur bur are all
right. That is it. That is the podcast. Uh, let's go cubbies.
I wanna see a game seven and then, um, it's,
I don't want to see the one that you guys lose. You know what I mean?
You've both waited long enough, but, uh,
I got a root for the cubs and Games six cause I want to see a game. Seven.
All right. That's it. I got my app. The NHL app is working for me now.
I'll be watching Bruins games and that type of shit and I'm going to try to
watch that. A Formula One race, uh, for all you fucking gear heads out there.
All right, go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday.